eu agriculture ministers will exchange
views in luxembourg
on a report on the functioning of the
fruit and vegetable sector
since reforms were introduced in 2007.
the report concerns the implementation
of provisions on producer organizations
operational funds and operational
programs
the 2007 reform aim to strengthen the
role of fruit and vegetable producer
organizations
it provides a wider range of tools to
help prevent and manage
market crises incentives were created to
encourage
mergers between producer organizations
and associations
and to foster transnational cooperation
however the report points out that
there's little or no organization in the
fruit and vegetable sector in some eu
regions
this rules out benefits of specific aid
for seen for the sector
it also weakens the bargaining power of
producers within the supply chain
based on results from the minister's
debate the european commission could
later present the legislative proposals
to revise the eu
aid scheme for the fruit and vegetable
sector